if you are craving more force awakens
and you want answers to some of your
lingering questions then developer TT
fusion will help you out with the next
lego star wars game speaking with Game
Informer head of design Mike Taylor
pointed out that the studio has been
given the green light to expand the
force awakens lore and include tie-in
material for example we'll learn where
c-3po got his red arm a question will
have answered in comic book form in
March Taylor went on to say the thing
with the force awakens is that we've had
the privilege of being able to create
some additional content some additional
levels that take place before the events
of the force awakens and allow us to
explore some of the backstory of the
characters which is an absolute dream
for any fan of Star Wars six of the
game's missions will involve this extra
backstory but we'll have to wait until
June twenty eighth to play them right
side it's coming to ps4 ps3 xbox one
xbox 360 Wii U 3ds and PC and we'll have
it all covered on gamespot
you